Donald Trump is demanding that climate
change quote come back because it was
cold yesterday in parts of the United
States of course in the northern
hemisphere it's what we know of as
winter right now and the problem with
this is that there are actually a lot of
low information people voters some of
them who confuse climate change with
weather and we've been dealing with this
confusion for a really really long time
and much like with most of our problems
if people weren't just ignorant to the
facts we wouldn't be dealing with a lot
of these issues to begin with
anti-vaccine sentiment is an example
people who think supply-side economics
works I could give you many examples but
today we're talking about people who
either don't understand or are
pretending not to understand the
difference between weather and climate
and there's a really long history of
climate change deniers who deny climate
change by pointing to a cold day often
in winter in parts of the country where
it's normally cold in winter here's one
example one of my favorites from Fox
News from years ago at this point
outside and it is frightful currently
for the most part the 48 connected
states are nice and dry with the
exception of the Pacific Northwest
that's the good news the bad news is man
is it cold right now in Minneapolis the
air temperature is 9 below zero
International Falls in Minnesota
yesterday had a recorded temperature of
37 degrees below zero that is the
coldest temperature that town has had
since 1911 yeah that global warming
things really kicking into high gear
isn't it wait so you're telling me that
in winter it was cold in Minnesota
clearly climate change couldn't possibly
be real right and I have a ton of these
clips that I could play for you I'm not
going to today I think you understand it
what's at issue here is whether versus
climate when we talk about whether we're
talking about the day-to-day state of
the atmosphere the short term variation
over a few minutes a few hours days
maybe even a couple of weeks climate is
the weather of a place over a long
period of time years Dec
thirty years we could say when we talk
about is it a record cold or a record
hot day today or this week that's really
a conversation about the weather when we
say Oh over the last 10 years we've had
more and more record high and low
temperatures every single year on
average those are conversations about
climate and how climate is changing over
time when we talk about a particular
hurricane we're talking about a weather
event but when we talk about the
connection to climate on the basis of
how many more and more serious
hurricanes are we having over a long
period of time that becomes a
conversation about the climate so in
comes Donald Trump known for claiming
that climate change is a hoax concocted
by the Chinese and last night he decides
to tweet quote in the in the beautiful
Midwest wind chill temperatures are
reaching minus 60 degrees the coldest
ever recorded in coming days expected to
get even colder people can't last
outside even four minutes what the hell
is going on with global warming please
come back fast we need you whether Trump
actually believes this or not this is
weaponized ignorant that's what that
that's a term that unfortunately we've
had to use a lot during this
administration for a very long time I
was 100% convinced that Donald Trump was
trolling people with his climate change
nonsense about China and whatever else I
am more and more convinced Pat that he
genuinely doesn't get it and that this
is not him merely trying to trigger
people who believe the science like on
many issues I think Trump actually
doesn't understand what's going on same
here I think he does buy into the
climate change doesn't exist conspiracy
theory and he's definitely spreading it
whenever he's asked about climate change
he just reiterates that we want clean
air and clean water but that's all he'll
say and I remember a couple months back
during the California wildfires he
visited the land there and promised that
they would never happen again so what is
he doing to ensure that promise nothing
essentially yeah it's it's truly bizarre
and just as a point I mean I
point I've said this so many times
before every serious climate change
model predicts erratic weather meaning
record highs and record lows the fact
that it's cold in winter should not be
news in any way when it comes to weather
versus climate but in addition to that
when you actually talk about climate
climate change models indicate that you
would see regularly set high
temperatures record high temperatures
and record low temperatures and that's
why this anti intellectualism and
pseudo-intellectual ism in some cases in
the Republican Party this is the party
where a senator brought in a snowball to
the Senate thinking that that in some
way has any bearing on the issue of
climate change in the environment and
pollution this is a weaponization of
anti-intellectualism and also
anti-education sentiment and it is quite
literally putting our planet at risk
it's not a figure of speech or a
metaphor it is putting the planet at
risk and the president of the United
States is a part of the problem and is
being laughed at by leaders around the
world who simply don't include him in
conversations about how to deal with
this issue anymore today's program was
made possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman better help is an online
service that gives you access to your
own experienced fully licensed therapist
via phone video and text when you see a
therapist in person in their office it
can take three weeks on average before
you're able to get in for your first
appointment but with better help you're
matched with a therapist who fits your
needs within just 24 hours and you get
the same professional service and the
best part is that better help is less
expensive than seeing a therapist in
person as well plus you will have
totally unlimited access to the
therapist you can talk to them whenever
you want on your phone or computer and
because better help believes in what
they do they also have a full money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
service you'll get a full refund no
questions asked all of their therapists
go through an extensive vetting process
and are required to have at least three
years of experience before joining
better help so you know you're getting
someone who's fully qualified to help
you but if you don't think that your
therapist is a good fit better help lets
you switch to someone new at anytime if
you've been thinking about getting
involved with therapy you should really
check out better help just click the
link underneath this video